For experts in emotion interview.
Today we have the honor of speaking with Dr. Tour Waker.
Dr Wagger is the director of the cognitive and affective neuroscience laboratory
at the University of Colorado,
Boulder,
boulder and received his phd from the University of Michigan and cognitive
psychology with a focus in cognitive neuroscience.
In 2003 he joined the Faculty of Columbia University as an assistant professor
in 2004 and was appointed associate professor in 2009 and recently in 2010 he
joined the Faculty of the Department of Psychology and neuroscience at the
University of Colorado Boulder.
Uh,
doctor wiggers research focuses on how expectations shape responses to pain and
emotion in the brain and body.
His work integrates new and novel analytic and Mehta analytic methods,
f Mri and psychophysiology.
He's published over 60 articles and received numerous awards including
innovation award from the social and aspect of neuroscience society,
as well as the Janet Taylor Spence award from the association for Psychological
Science.
His work has been highly featured in media outlets,
including the New York Times,
La Times,
National Geographic,
the Huffington post,
science,
daily,
CNN,
and more.
So I now turn with great pleasure to our experts and emotion interview with
Doctor Tor Waker on the question of where exactly is emotion in the brain.
So welcome tour.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Thanks for having me.
So what,
I wanted to start out asking you a bit about what sort of,
what got you interested in emotion in the first place,
sort of where did the journey begin for you?
I've been interested in emotion for a long time.
I started off studying cognitive controlling graduate school and working memory.
And that's important stuff,
but emotion is really important because I think it's an organizing principle
that guides how we structure our lives and our everyday interactions.
So I think that's why I've been guided towards that for years now.
All right,
cool.
So I wanted the nasty a little bit about where the years have taken you,
you know,
since he's gotten interested in this topic.
So,
I mean,
you've done a lot of things and um,
so where do I begin asking you about your work is always a challenge because you
done so many exciting things.
But one of the things I want to start with is just your work where you've
conducted this really impressive,
you know,
and widely influential Meta analysis on the neuroanatomy of emotion,
particularly in the human brain.
And I wondered if you could just say a little bit in doing this,
you know,
Meta analysis,
what you found to be some of the most exciting discoveries out there?
Um,
yeah,
we,
we started,
uh,
Gosh,
I think about 10 years ago now and we've been continuing to do med analyses and
we have several things that are ongoing.
So it's really a series people started off,
I think with some sort of relatively simple ideas about emotion.
Uh,
it was,
it's been harder to get a handle on emotion then it has other sorts of cognitive
phenomena that are easier to study experimentally.
So people had these ideas like,
uh,
the,
the right hemisphere is the emotional hemisphere and there's less right
lateralization for positive versus negative emotion.
And what we've found with the met analysis for one thing is that it's much more
complicated than that.
Uh,
the pattern of lateralization is more complicated and the pattern of
interactions that creates a signature for each,
a different kind of emotion if there is one is I'm not as straight forward to
find.
So I think people also started off with the idea that,
uh,
that there's a region that codes for a particular emotion.
Like the Amygdala is fear and the insula is discussed.
And,
um,
certainly each of those regions participates in that process.
But one of the things that we found is that most of the regions involved in
emotional processes participate in multiple kinds of,
of processes.
So I think it points towards the fact that we have a lot more work to do to
understand what the signature is of a particular emotional state.
So it's not just the Amygdala,
uh,
um,
it's something much broader.
Uh,
you know,
one of the things that led us to believe that is if you look at what the
Amygdala response to in human neuroimaging studies that responds to faces,
the making facial expressions of emotion,
they don't even have to be consciously perceived.
And so that's quite different than then identifying,
they make the law with the experience of fear.
Yeah.
So I mean,
it's interesting,
it sounds like from this med analysis,
the land sort of landscape of where we think about emotion as being sort of,
you know,
placed in the human brain is much more complex than we could ever appreciate.
Um,
and from what you're saying,
it sounds like this met analysis provided an interesting road map for maybe
where researchers should be,
you know,
spending their energy's moving forward.
That's right.
It's helped us to evaluate what's consistently coming out in the human neuro
imaging literature and,
uh,
and,
and what's not and how,
uh,
how general versus specific are the profiles of activity in different regions
and our future work.
Um,
we're sort of pursuing that.
We're trying to understand is there a signature,
a signature for each different kind of emotional state.
That's really exciting.
I mean one of the other things you've been doing that I think is also really
interesting is studying,
you know,
machine learning as sort of one route towards,
providing specificity as to whether some of these observed patterns,
you know,
of neural activity might represent,
potential biomarkers of underlying aspect of processing.
And this is also an area I think that's a really exciting,
really new in this domain.
And I wonder from your perspective,
what are some of the promise that this approach could provide for people trying
to study,
you know,
emotion and the human brain?
Great.
So machine learning,
uh,
income.
This is a very broad set of techniques in a very important one for finding
patterns from complex multivariate data and developed in statistics and computer
science for those reasons to find those patterns.
Uh,
I think it's really important the application of those techniques to brain
imaging data in particular.
Um,
because it does a couple things for us.
One is we can ask the questions about is there a unique neuro or brain signature
for a particular type of process,
whether it's pain or sadness.
I don't think we've yet found pain or sadness or joy or disgust in the brain.
We don't really know what time,
what the processes are that contribute to those things and they would probably
differ based on the situation.
So machine learning offers a way forward to anchor our Britain analyses on
these,
uh,
on the outcomes that we care about,
on the psychological outcomes that we care about.
And so that's very exciting and I think,
you know,
it's going to be interesting to see how machine learning and the use of machine
learning involves,
uh,
as a trend and in the human neurosciences.
Um,
I think there's a few sort of hold over ideas,
uh,
that are,
are probably,
um,
myths or at least been in some ways they're miss.
Uh,
one of them is that,
um,
the machine learning is a complex procedure that yields are very complicated
pattern and it's hard to understand and it doesn't have to be the case.
Um,
and so I think with the right kinds of,
of judicious use of those techniques,
I really do think that we're going to be able to move forwards towards
understanding psychological and,
and um,
and,
and behavioral principles.
Exciting.
I mean,
so I mean you've done really neat work dazing Meta analysis techniques,
looking at the role of machine learning and you've also done some work on a
topic that I think is really familiar and controversial to many people,
which is the placebo effect.
And you've done some really interesting work looking at the placebo effect as it
relates to the experience of pain.
And I wondered if you could just say a little bit about these findings that have
really captivated a wide audience.
Great.
Um,
I,
I've always been fascinated by the ways in which conceptual processes,
things that you think about,
recall from memory,
et Cetera,
can,
can influence a health related outcomes.
And so you could view placebo effects through this lens.
In part,
it's a way of understanding how we can,
you know,
you,
you can actually create a laboratory paradigm where you experimentally
manipulate someone's beliefs about a situation or about the context and then you
can quantify outcomes that are relevant for,
for health and disease in various ways.
And so that's kind of for me,
one of the things that's interesting about placebo effects,
um,
another,
an in a sort of another angle on that is this,
it is clinically relevant.
People haven't yet or they don't understand what happens.
What's,
what are the implications of when you give people a placebo treatment in a
clinical trial?
Um,
and does the drug just sort of work on top of the placebo if there is a placebo
effect or does it interact with that,
um,
that,
that placebo effect?
And so,
you know,
I think there's,
clinically speaking,
I think there's this opportunity to contribute to a shift from thinking about
drugs and treatments as agents that act on a very simple mechanical system,
which is a brain towards thinking about the brain as a very complex,
responsive,
not just reactive evolving system and the effects of pharmacological treatments
operate in this highly dynamic environment.
So you really,
you know,
I think it's the clinical aspect is there's this promise that it can help to put
the,
the brain back into biomedicine as a colleague of mine used to say.
Um,
and I think from a psychological perspective,
it's interesting to me because placebo effects a sit at the nexus of conceptual
processes and beliefs,
um,
learning processes and memory,
episodic memory retrieval and how you recall context and,
and effect and how emotional processes are generated in the brain.
And so I think that they're kind of,
you know,
provides a kind of a window into this central integrative organization of how
we,
how the brain shapes motivation and an effect.
Uh,
and so,
and that makes it complicated to study.
But also I think interesting in a lot of different directions.
I mean,
one of the interesting things here that people often wonder is sort of,
well how do placebo treatments work in the first place?
Like what are the kind of necessary ingredients or components that really make
placebo treatments work?
And I don't know what your thoughts are on this.
Yeah,
I,
you know,
I thought so are evolved.
My thoughts are evolving on that and they've really been shaped by the research
that we're doing.
So I was surprised,
really,
honestly surprised years ago when we did the first studies and found out that,
um,
essentially placebo treatments can change the way the brain processes pain.
They can cause changes in endogenous opioid release.
Um,
and so how,
how do they work?
I think we're still very much figuring that out.
But some of the things that we now know and I think are really important are,
it's not just about belief.
I don't think you can manipulate someone's belief without introducing a placebo
effects on brain processes that are meaningful.
And it's not just about conditioning or learning.
It's not sort of a passive,
uh,
you know,
behavioristic kind of process because you can give people all the experiences
that are consistent with a placebo effect.
They should create one and not get that.
And so where we're headed now is towards developing models that combine,
uh,
ideas about learning in the brain and plasticity with ideas about conceptual
thought.
And the basic core idea is that if you have the right kind of belief and you get
the right kind of have experience to back it up,
then there is a,
a process of,
uh,
changing the response to especially affective and motivational events in the
brain.
So that's just a little,
a little bit I'm at and we're learning a lot I think right now.
I mean,
then you talk about all these things you've done in sort of the next steps in
what you're learning and where you're going.
And it makes me wonder from your perspective,
someone who really is a leader in this field,
you know,
where do you see the face of the future headed as we,
as we look forward and try to decide where to go next?
Well,
I think there are a number of exciting things happening in our field.
Really.
I think there's kind of an explosion.
Um,
for me personally,
one of the things I think is very exciting is the idea of anchoring
the psychological concepts of emotion onto brain processes so that we can,
and as we make that mapping between brain and emotion,
we can then start to use the brain to understand the emotional processes better.
So I don't think right now we can,
I don't think anybody can really look at a brain scan of any kind and say,
oh,
this person was feeling joyful and this person was feeling melancholy.
Well,
this person was feeling good versus bad.
Um,
and,
but I think that it's possible that we could develop those measures.
And so for me,
I think the idea of anchoring the study of emotions in biology is an extremely
important one.
And so when students then come to you and ask,
you know,
where should I be going?
You know,
as I'm embarking in this study of emotion,
or what advice do you have for someone like me,
his thinking about maybe entering this field,
right?
What do you tell them sort of,
what is your advice to students who are dabbling or thinking about studying
emotion and the human brain?
Um,
I,
I think that I think everyone thinks in a very different way and each person has
a profile of strengths or weaknesses in the way they think and interests.
And so I guess my advice to students would be to find something that really fits
defined,
uh,
area of study in a way of studying it that plays to your strengths so that
you're capitalizing on what you're really excited about.
I think,
you know,
you've got to love what you're doing or,
or find a way to do that.
You don't have to love everything about it.
Um,
but that,
that's kind of my,
you know,
my broad advice.
And you know,
for me personally,
I,
I like to think about the connections between I think what I'm doing and,
and lots of different kinds of areas,
people doing very different kinds of things,
at least as much as possible.
Um,
and I liked the technical development.
so those things are just exciting to me.
I do them late at night,
but you know,
I find myself still program and you know,
not everybody has to be like that.
Um,
but,
but I think each person can find the way in which they really can contribute in
a unique way and,
and fit into that.
Hmm.
So love what you're doing and also find what you're good at and really go at it.
You know,
like your tour staying up till late at night programming way.
Guess my better judgment.
Yeah.
Well toward,
thanks for speaking with us today.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you June.
It's really been fun.
Well,
thanks.
So this concludes our experts and emotion interview with Doctor Tour wigger from
the University of Colorado at Boulder.
Thanks again.